what I was trying to when I was trying
to separate these two terms it's not
like there's no bridge between them
right these are two ends of a spectrum
and right like it's something that could
start out at hashtag me too could slowly
over time morph into me to going too far
into trial by meeting I think that's
what the spectrum like I think the four
of us are setting up this spectrum of
like responses to sexual assault and you
know responses can happen anywhere along
that that line I also would say that
that social movements are like occupied
by many people who have very different
visions of what that social movement is
like there are so many feminists who do
feminism very differently from how I
would do feminism and then it's not like
I can go around saying well they're not
real feminists but it means that like
they're definitely it's like you know
when someone says like there are when we
we can all acknowledge for example that
there are very bad drivers it doesn't
mean that everyone should stop driving
cars it means there are people who drive
in ways that we wouldn't agree with
right it's the same way with social
movements right there are many people
who don't use hashtag me - the way that
I've historically wanted to talk about
sexual assault for myself and like I
think like personally I never named my
attacker he for some reason named
himself and that was always interesting
to me because then it kind of spun into
like at least within the community at
Columbia and then started to snowball
into the rest of America and now hi I'm
here in London into a sort of trial by
media so I think I would have loved for
my case to have been handled with
discretion so that I didn't have to talk
about rape every time I meet someone at
a party right but this is I think that
this is proof of society's hunger for
these kinds of stories
you